Speaker 2: Let's go to Terrance from
Delaware. Terrance, what's going on?
Speaker 4: All right, David, it's good to
talk to you. Thank you for your concern. I've
been watching you since around the January six
incident. Thank you. I just have a quick question.
So. For the average person. What do you
think is the most effective thing that they
can do? And I'm going to give you an example
because I know it's sort of a broad question.
So for me, the most important issue is facing
Americans and humanity is climate change and
sort of environmental protections. And so I would
say the most important things are sort of voting
and then maybe putting your your money towards
politicians that favor environmentalism. Right.
It's sort of hard for me as an individual
to invest in long term environmentalism,
but I would say that's the most important
for for that particular issue. So I don't
know if you have a good answer to that question.
Speaker 2: I mean, these it's the question about
the meta issues, which I've talked about a little
before. How our politics is financed is one of the
most important things. Climate and environment,
as you're talking about, is one of the most
important things, how our elections are managed
and held, which by which we're talking about,
you know, first past the post voting, etc.,
making sure everybody votes and then media
coverage of political issues. Those to me are the
most important for meta issues. And whatever you
care about, be it education or abortion or
whatever, I think it comes from down there
downstream from those four issues. So I think
voting and working on those four issues are the
most important things we can do.
Speaker 4: Great. Thank you.
Speaker 2: All right. Terrance from
Delaware, very much appreciate the call.